Nace un niño
y por mucho tiempo
es un consumidor.
No puede contribuir conscientemente.
Está indefenso.
Ni siquiera sabe cómo sobrevivir,
aunque está dotado con un instinto de supervivencia.
Necesita ayuda de su madre, o una madre adoptiva, para sobrevivir.
No puede permitirse dudar de la persona que lo cuida.
Tiene que rendirse completamente.
como uno se rinde ante un anestesiólogo.
Tiene que entregarse completamente.
Esto implica mucha confianza.
Implica que la persona en quien confía
no romperá esa confianza.
Conforme el niño crece,
comienza a descubrir
que la persona en la que confía está violando su confianza.
Ni siquiera conoce la palabra "violación".
Por lo tanto, tiene que culparse a sí mismo.
Una culpa silenciosa,
que es más difícil de resolver,
la auto-culpa silenciosa.
A medida que el niño crece para convertirse en un adulto,
hasta ahora, ha sido un consumidor,
pero el crecimiento de un ser humano,
yace en su capacidad para colaborar,
de ser un contribuyente.
Uno no puede contribuir a menos que se sienta seguro,
uno se sienta grande,
uno siente: "Tengo suficiente".
Ser compasivo no es una broma.
No es así de simple.
Uno tiene que descubrir cierta grandeza en uno mismo.
Esa grandeza debe estar centrada en uno mismo,
no en términos de dinero,
no en términos del poder que tienes,
no en términos de cualquier estatus que puedas alcanzar en la sociedad,
pero debe estar centrada en uno mismo.
El Yo, tú eres auto-conciencia.
En ese Yo, debe estar centrada, una grandeza, una totalidad,
de lo contrario, compasión es solo un palabra y un sueño.
Puedes ser compasivo ocasionalmente,
motivado más por empatía
que por compasión.
Gracias a Dios que somos empáticos.
Cuando alguien está en sufriendo, tomamos ese dolor.
En un partido de Wimbledon, en una final,
estos dos sujetos compiten.
Cada uno tiene dos juegos.
Puede ganar cualquiera.
Todo lo que han sudado hasta ahora no tiene sentido.
Solo ganará uno.
En el tennis el protocolo indica que los jugadores tienen que acercarse a la red
y estrechar sus manos.
El ganador golpea el aire
y besa la pista,
lanza su camiseta como si alguien la estubiera esperando.
(Risas)
Y este tipo tiene que ir a la red.
Cuando se acerca a la red,
verán, todo su rostro cambia.
Parece que desearía no haber ganado.
¿Por qué? Empatía.
Eso es el corazón humano.
A ningún humano se le niega tal empatía.
Ninguna religión puede destruir eso mediante adoctrinamiento.
Ninguna cultura, ni nación, ni nacionalismo.
nada puede tocarla,
porque es empatía.
Y esa capacidad para empatizar,
es la ventana a través de la cual llegas a la gente,
para hacer algo que marque la diferencia en la vida de alguien.
Incluso las palabras o el tiempo.
La compasión no se define de una sola manera.
No hay compasión hindú.
No hay compasión americana.
La compasión trasciende las naciones, el género, la edad.
¿Por qué? Porque se encuentra en todos y cada uno de nosotros.
La gente la experimenta ocasionalmente.
De esta compasión ocasional
no estamos hablando,
Nunca permanecerá ocasional.
Por mandato, no puedes hacer a una persona compasiva.
No puedes decir, "Por favor, ámame".
El Amor es algo que descubres por ti mismo.
No es una acción,
pero en la lengua inglesa, también es una acción.
Hablaré de eso después.
Así que uno tiene que descubrir cierta unidad.
Y voy a citar la posibilidad de ser alguien completo,
lo cual se encuentra dentro de nuestra experiencia, la experiencia de todos.
A pesar de una vida trágica,
uno es feliz en momentos que son muy escasos y distantes.
Y el que es feliz,
incluso por una bufonada,
se acepta a sí mismo, y también la manera en que uno se autodescubre.
Eso significa todo el universo,
las cosas conocidas y desconocidas.
Todas ellas son totalmente aceptadas
porque descubres la plenitud en ti mismo.
El sujeto, yo,
y el objeto, la forma de las cosas,
fusionadas en la unidad,
una experiencia de la que nadie puede decir: "Estoy privado de...";
una experiencia común para todos sin excepción.
Esa experiencia confirma que, a pesar de todas tus limitaciones,
de todos tus deseos, anhelos incompletos, y de las tarjetas de crédito,
y despidos,
y, finalmente, a pesar de la calvicie,
puedes ser feliz.
La extensión de la lógica no dice
que no necesitas satisfacer tus deseos para ser feliz.
Tú eres la propia felicidad, la totalidad, lo que quieres ser.
No hay elección en esto.
Solo confirma la realidad
de que la totalidad no puede ser diferente de ti,
no puede ser menos que tú.
Tiene que ser Tú,
No puedes ser parte de la totalidad
y aún así estar completo.
Tu momento de felicidad revela esa realidad,
esa comprensión, ese reconocimiento,
Quizá yo soy la unidad.
Quizá el swami tiene razón.
Quizá el swami tiene razón. Comienzas una nueva vida.
Y entonces todo cobra sentido.
Yo no tengo más motivos para culparme a mí mismo.¥
Si uno tiene que culparse a sí mismo, uno tiene un millón de razones y más,
pero si digo, a pesar de que mi cuerpo está limitado,
si es negro, no es blanco, si es blanco, no es negro,
tu cuerpo está limitado en la manera en que lo mires. Limitado.
Tus conocimientos son limitados, tu salud es limitada,
y el poder por lo tanto es limitado,
y la alegría va a ser limitada.
La compasión va a ser limitada.
Todo va a ser ilimitado.
No puedes ordenar compasión
a menos que llegues a ser ilimitado, y nadie puede volverse ilimitado,
o eres o no eres. Punto.
Y tampoco hay manera de que no seas ilimitado.
Tu propia experiencia revela, que a pesar de todas tus limitaciones, tu eres la totalidad.
Y esa plenitud es tu realidad
cuando te relacionas con el mundo.
Es primero amor.
Cuando te relacionas con el mundo,
la manifestación dinámica de la unidad
es lo que llamamos amor.
Y se convierte en compasión
si el objeto con el que te relacionas provoca esa emoción.
Entonces nuevamente se transforma en dar, en compartir.
Te expresas porque tienes compasión.
Para descubrir la compasión, tienes que ser compasivo.
Para descubrir la capacidad de dar y compartir,
necesitas dar y compartir.
No hay atajo. Es como nadar nadando.
Aprendes a nadar nadando.
No puedes aprender a nadar en un colchón y luego entrar en el agua.
(Risas)
Aprendes a nadar nadando. Aprendes a montar en bicicleta montando en bicicleta.
Aprendes a cocinar cocinando,
teniendo gente comprensiva a tu alrededor
que se coma lo que cocinas.
(Risas)
y por lo tanto, lo que digo,
tienes que fingir y hacerlo.
(Risas)
Necesitas hacerlo.
Mi predecesor quiso decir eso.
Tienes que actuarlo.
Tienes que actuar compasivamente.
No hay verbo para compasión,
pero tienes un adverbio para compasión.
Eso es interesante para mí.
Actúas compasivamente.
¿Pero cómo actuar compasivamente si no tienes compasión?
Ahí es cuando finges.
Finges y lo haces. Este es el mantra de los Estados Unidos de América.
(Risas)
Finges y lo haces.
Actúas compasivamente como si tuvieras compasión,
rechinas los dientes,
tomas todo el sistema de ayuda,
si sabes como rezar, rezas.
Pides compasión.
Déjame actuar compasivamente.
Hazlo.
Descubrirás la compasión
y también lentamente una compasión familiar,
y lentamente, quizá si obtienes la enseñanza correcta,
descubrirás que la compasión es una manifestación dinámica
de tu propia realidad, que es la unidad, la totalidad,
y eso es lo que eres.
Con estas palabras, muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)